[Applaudissements]
merci à tous en messieurs en avant voilà
alors est-ce que d'abord vous m'entendez
correctement parfait oui ou non
[Musique]
j'ai des retours contrasté qui m'amène à
penser que ceux qui répondent non
est ce que le niveau sonore est bon là
ça va mieux encore un tout petit peu si
c'est possible
voilà l'otan comme monsieur zemmour
parle nettement plus vite est nettement
moins fort que moi il vaut mieux que ce
soit tout de suite bien dosé d'abord on
est très heureux de vous accueillir et
vous êtes chez vous eric est ici chez
lui parce que nous sommes dans une
maison je veux que le débat soit libre
et ouvert les républicains veulent qu'on
réfléchisse on a besoin de se
questionner sur où va notre pays sur les
difficultés auxquelles il est confronté
sur les espoirs qu'ils peuvent être les
siens et guillaume larrivé a fait un
immense travail je l'en remercie pour
faire en sorte que ces rendez vous soit
ouvert à des intellectuels qui font du
bien notre pays parce que comme le
disait montaigne y frotte la cervelle et
on a besoin de se frotter la cervelle
pour être plus précis encore on a besoin
que ce rendez vous soit ouvert à des
personnalités qui secoue cette espèce de
gang de penser toute prête avec laquelle
on organise que michel houellebecq
appelle la soumission
c'est à dire petit à petit la démission
des idées le fait qu'on ne voit plus ce
qu'on voit qu'on ne dit plus ce qui nous
scandalise parfois et qu'on renonce tout
simplement à débattre ensemble de ce
qu'on souhaite pour notre pays la
personne qui est à côté moi est une
figure libre et je suis heureux qu'il
soit ainsi parce que c'est un être
auquel on ne dit pas ses idées etc on
intimide pas
[Applaudissements]
eric au delà de nos différences et nous
en avons nous ne sommes pas d'accord sur
tout il n'est pas d'accord avec tout ce
que je pense je ne suis pas d'accord
avec tout ce qu'ils pensent il fait
partie de ceux qui ont contribué à
ouvrir les yeux de la france sur ce qui
était en train de se passer et notamment
sur les dérives du communautarisme
le danger de l'intégrisme l'effritement
petit à petit de notre roman national
ce livre que j'ai ici est un immense
travail
j'ai beaucoup de plaisir à échanger avec
eric avant qu'il se lance dans cette
entreprise colossale qui m'a raconté
d'ailleurs au tout début c'est un
immense travail dgt archives de
recherche de réflexion de mise à
distance de quoi de ce qu'est l'histoire
de france
ce que eric revisite c'est l'histoire du
grand roman national et quand vous lisez
ce livre ce qui fait d'abord plaisir
c'est de retrouver l'histoire de france
telle qu'on l'enseigné cette histoire de
france qui était transmise à nos enfants
comme un legs précieux avec de grandes
figures
c'est ce qu'eric restitue vous croiserez
vercingétorix vous croiserez clovis vous
croiserez la figure évidemment de
napoléon bonaparte ou de de gaulle mais
vous croiserez aussi des gens moins
connus que j'avais même parfois mois
oublier nogaret maupéou des figures
aussi qu'ils sont revisités pour le rôle
triste qu'elles ont eues dans l'héritage
de notre pays talleyrand madame de staël
qui voltaire même qui est analysée avec
un regard différent la figure de
françois 1er qui était pourtant un roi
que moi j'aimais beaucoup mais dont eric
souligne avec justesse qu'il a eu aussi
certains travers que féérique avec cela
il restitue aussi ce qu'est son parcours
à lui d'un enfant issu d'une famille
juive et qui a profondément chéri et
aimé dès sa tendre enfance
les valeurs de la culture républicain le
parcours d'une intégration
et d'un choix profond porté
charnellement de son amour de la france
ce que j'aime au fond dans ce que eric
nous raconte c'est qu'ils nous racontent
deux choses d'abord il nous dit que
notre nation est une nation
exceptionnelle qui a eu un destin
exceptionnel qui est un parcours qui
s'est imposé dans le grand combat des
grandes puissances à la fois en europe
et dans le monde qui aurait pu connaître
un autre destin être soumise au joug de
l'espagne comme eric le rappel qui
aurait pu ne pas être capable de se
faufiler ce grand affrontement
pluriséculaire avec l'angleterre qui se
prolonge encore aujourd'hui dans les
batailles de la mondialisation que le
destin de la france est exceptionnel et
qu'il mérite autre chose qu'un travail
de contrition dans lequel on ne cesse de
s'excuser de ce qu'est l'histoire de
france qui mérite un travail de fierté
c'est la première leçon que nous
rappelle éric vous voulez que notre pays
rayonnent
il doit être fier de lui et fière de son
histoire c'est la première chose que
eric nous apprend à travers ce livre est
la deuxième chose qui nous apprend c'est
que la france n'a été grande que quand
elle assumait les valeurs qui étaient
les siennes que quand elle assumait ce
qu'elle était et qu'à intervalles
réguliers dans notre histoire il ya cet
affrontement qu'eric explique
parfaitement entre ceux qui ont misé sur
la déconstruction du pays la haine de la
france des gens qui petit à petit y ont
tourné le refus de ce qu'était notre
pays ont contribué à le désagréger dans
une espèce de protection + ou -
universaliste dans laquelle on a oublié
nos racines notre culture notre identité
et de l'autre côté les grandes figures à
l'image de richelieu qui ont tenu
fermement le cap et n'ont jamais abdiqué
sur le fait que la france n'était jamais
aussi grande que quand elle assumait son
identité ce qu'était sa culture et ses
valeurs
c'est pour moi la plus belle des leçons
que ce que nous apporte
eric zemmour à travers cet ouvrage c'est
un formidable invitation au débat
nous ne serons pas d'accord avec tout
mais au moins voilà quelqu'un qui secoue
la poussière et je voudrais finir avec
quelque chose erika d'admirables
citation moi il y en a une que j'aime et
qui est évidemment un écho pour toi
c'est celle de simone weill
la philosophe qui rappelait quelque
chose il faut donner quelque chose a
aimé et ce qu'elle
chose ce doit être la france voilà ce
que féérique merci à lui maintenant ça
maintenant qu'il a tout dit ce qu'il y
avait dans mon livre je vais pouvoir
raconter quelques babioles d'abord
bonsoir bonsoir à vous tous merci d'être
aussi nombreux d'être aussi chaleureux
merci à laurent wauquiez de me recevoir
dans ses murs merci à guillaume larrivé
d'avoir organiser tout ça merci à vous
tous d'être venus là j'en vois beaucoup
de beaux merci à vous je suis très
touché de cet accueil chaleureux et jeu
je vais essayer de de ne pas faire
démentir le le vibrant éloge et qui a
fait de moi
laurent wauquiez en fait si j'ai bien
compris ceux non ma feuille de route de
ce soir je vous propose de vous
expliquer pendant 15 20 minutes
pourquoi j'ai écrit ce livre qu'est ce
qui m'a vraiment motivé et ensuite je
répondrai volontiers à vos questions
soit sur l'histoire soit sur le livre
soit sur l'actualité pour essayer de
comme je le fais déjà dans le livre de
2,2 de rattraper de raccorder de
comprendre aujourd'hui paris hier et
hier par aujourd'hui car je pense que
non pas selon la phrase paresseuse que
l'histoire se répète elle ne se répète
pas mais en revanche les l'homme l'homme
est toujours le même comme disait
tocqueville l'histoire c'est beaucoup de
copies et peu d'originaux et surtout les
situations se répètent les situations
concorde des situations nous nous
rapproche de nos ancêtres et c'est là
qui est intéressant le jugement ces lacs
est intéressant de savoir ce qu'ils ont
fait et j'en viens directement au fait
c'est justement pour cela que j'ai écrit
ce livre parce qu'après tout comme me le
répète suffisamment mes détracteurs je
ne suis pas historien professionnelle
loin de là je n'ai pas je ne suis pas à
l'université et je n'ai pas de
légitimité pour eux et j'ai écrit ce
livre justement pour leur répondre
parce que justement nous avons une école
d'historiens une université qui depuis
30 ou 40 ans explique deux choses la
première le contraire de ce que je viens
de vous dire c'est à dire qu'il n'ya pas
de leçons en histoire que chaque
événement est indépendant qu'on ne doit
pas tiré de leçon en histoire c'est à
dire qu'elle nous ils nous interdisent
de penser l'histoire par rapport à
aujourd'hui
alors que des générations précédentes
d'historiens ne faisait que raconter une
histoire en fonction des problématiques
d'aujourd'hui et d'ailleurs vous je vous
paie montrera après que c'est ce qu'ils
font eux mêmes raconter une histoire qui
soit en fonction des problématiques
d'aujourd'hui mais ils nous interdisent
de faire de même ça c'est une première
chose
et la deuxième chose pourquoi ça
s'appelle destin français c'est parce
que il explique à longueur de colonnes à
longueur de cours dans les universités à
longueur de thèse que la france
l'histoire de france n'existe pas et ils
veulent absolument démontrer que
l'histoire de france n'existe pas parce
qu'ils ont bien compris que la france
n'existait pas sans son histoire que la
france n'était pas une race que la
france n'était pas une ethnie que la
france n'était même pas à l'origine une
langue que la france n'est même pas une
géographie contrairement à ce qu'on
croit j'ai coutume de plaisanter avec
certains de mes amis qui me prennent
pour un sou pour moi la france ce n'est
pas l'hexagone
pour moi c'est
empire de napoléon de 1810 dans lequel
il y avait l'italie du nord l'allemagne
rhénane la belgique jeudi d'ailleurs
toujours à mes amis belges que pour eux
pour moi ils sont français qu'ils ne
sont belges que par le génie malsain des
anglais et que et de talleyrand et que
donc pour moi ils sont français
donc voyez jeu et peut considérer que la
france ce n'est pas l'hexagone
l'hexagone il faut bien que vous
compreniez ça c'est le produit d'une
défaite française
c'est une c'est une c'est une
géographique est le produit de la
défaite française de 1815 et qu'on n'a
jamais pu récupérer un territoire digne
de nos ambitions et digne d'ailleurs
deux des enjeux d'aujourd'hui mais c'est
un sujet que je reprendrai après si ça
vous intéresse deuxième raison donc pour
laquelle j'écris une histoire de france
c'est parce que pour les historiens
d'aujourd'hui il y a soit le monde
histoire mondiale de la france c'est à
dire la france n'est rien n'est que le
jouet des interactions de du monde soit
il s'arrête à des problématiques les
plus microscopique possible j'ai par
exemple ils vont vous faire une thèse
sur la théorie du genre en 1742 dans le
poitou et ça évidemment pour prendre un
peu de distance et un peu de recul sur
l'histoire de france c'est un peu
compliqué pourquoi font-ils ça ils font
ça pour deux raisons la première qui est
une raison légitime c'est que la
connaissance historique a tellement
augmenté l'ailé les les exigences
scientifiques de l'histoire on se sont
tellement accru que chacun est enfermé
dans sa micro sciences et dans sa micro
culture et donc il s'il évidemment il ne
voit que des choses les plus petit parce
qu'il laisse il
les approfondisse terriblement et puis
il y a une autre raison qui est beaucoup
plus idéologique qui et je dirai
beaucoup moins légitime c'est-à-dire que
ils veulent absolument montrer qu'il n'y
a pas de france que la france est une
création artificielle que la france est
une création injuste même inique qui
s'est bâtie sur le dos des victimes les
victimes c'est toujours les mêmes c'est
les vaincus ce sont les femmes ce sont
les colonisés la liste des victimes elle
est en libre service depuis 30 ans dans
toutes les télévisions et dans tous les
médias et dans toutes les universités
1 vous la connaissez aussi bien que moi
et donc la france c'est pas partie des
victimes elle fait partie des bourreaux
et donc il faut méthodiquement détruire
cette histoire de france il faut
méthodiquement montrer que tout ça
n'existe pas il faut en vérité
ridiculiser notre prétention à être une
nation est une grande nation comme
disaient les allemands au 19e siècle
et là l'objectif de l'histoire est
simple comme c'est l'histoire qui a fait
la france
c'est l'histoire qui va défaire la
france
leur ambition est énorme et leur
ambition est en voie d'être réussie si
vous regardez les livres d'histoire de
vos enfants de vos enfants des
adolescents c'est sidérant c'est
absolument sidérant louvre est un livre
d'histoire encore des années 70 et
ouvrez un livre d'histoire aujourd'hui
de 4e de troisième c'est absolument
impressionnant d'abord il n'y a plus
grand chose et surtout l'histoire de
france est noyée dans un ensemble qui
doit répondre aux problématiques
d'aujourd'hui je vais vous donner un
exemple que je donne toujours qui est
très simple pour l'histoire de la
révolution française
vous avez deux pages sur olympe de
gouges et vous avez ça sur robespierre
c'est l'histoire de france moderne et
pourquoi parce que robespierre est un
méchant donc la preuve alors expliqué
que c'est un méchant et un flou qui
voulait tuer tout le monde et vous avez
ensuite olympe de gouges pourquoi parce
que c'est une grande héroïne féministe
peu importe que tout le monde se foutait
d'olympe de gouges en 1793
j'ai coutume de dire que robespierre a
dû la faire guillotiner sans même savoir
qui c'était que pendant un siècle et
demi
ll est elle a absolument disparu de
l'histoire de france que c'est benoît de
groot dans les années 60 une écrivaine
comme elle disait qui l'a ressuscité et
qui a inventé ce personnage comme un
grand un personnage de la révolution
française ni me danton robespierre
mirabeau ce serait bien marrer il
n'existait pas pour eux hull et les
femmes qui connaissait c'était soit les
grandes duchesses soit les tricoteuses
qui surveillaient la
dans les assemblées pour que y ait des
condamnations à mort soit la grande
théroigne de méricourt qui avait été la
plus féroce dans les massacres du 2
septembre
ça y est les connaissait alors olympe de
gouges la déclaration des droits de la
femme etc
rayan mais vous avez bien compris que
peu importe puisque nos historiens sont
persuadés que l'histoire qu'on nous a
appris dans le passé était une
construction complètement artificielle
pour inventer une nation française qui
n'existaient pas ils se sentent tout à
fait légitimes à à leur tour inventé une
histoire qui correspondent aux
problématiques d'aujourd'hui et à
l'idéologie qui veulent faire passer
aujourd'hui et alors ils vont vous
expliquer que l'islam est à l'origine de
la france autant que le catholicisme et
ils vont vous inventer des histoires ils
vont vous expliquer que la bataille de
poitiers ce n'était rien voilà ça c'est
la nouvelle trouvaille la bataille de
poitiers charles martel tout ça c'est de
la rigolade
c'était comme ça ils avaient ils avaient
le choix entre une partie de foot et une
bataille et ils ont choisi la bataille
mais vraiment franchement il fallait pas
les pousser pour qu'il choisisse le
terrain de foot hein
ils vont vous expliquer que toute façon
il n'y a pas eu de vraie bataille et que
les conquérants arabes se sont était là
pour piller et que de toute façon ils
avaient ils ont raison perdu parce
qu'ils avaient trop de poids de leurs
pillages et qui sont allés piller
ailleurs ils oublient simplement de vous
dire que c'est en dans cette conception
de la guerre c'est à dire la guerre
conçu comme un pillage que ils ont
conquis la moitié de la planète et que
c'est comme ça qu'ils ont conquis
l'espagne
et c'est comme ça qu'ils ont conquis
tout le sud de la france c'était leur
manière de conquérir et donc quand
charles martel les arrête
c'est un coup d'arrêt majeur d'autant
plus et ça c'est le grand historien
américain qui explique sa hampe saône
qui explique que chaque civilisation à
son mode de combat et que le mode de
civilisation occidentale est née avec
les hoplites grecque qui justement ne
paient pas et faisait des affrontements
solide très dur pour détruire
l'adversaire c'était le génie de
l'occident charles martel comme par
hasard à retrouver dans cette bataille
les fondamentaux de la rome antique et
des fondamentaux de la de là comment
vous dire de de la stratégie romaine
donc vous voyez une simple bataille
je vous raconte cette simple bataille
pour montrer comment d'une même bataille
et peut raconter deux histoires
différentes
et si vous voulez moi ce que j'ai voulu
raconter c'est l'histoire de france du
point de vue français c'est ça en fait
le côté iconoclaste de ce livre par
rapport à tout ce qu'on a vécu depuis 40
ans
ce n'est pas non pas que la france est
tout fait bien non pas que la france est
toujours réussi loin de là non pas que
elle est qu'un bon côté à présenter
non pas que j'ai un ventre comme on me
reproche à un nouveau roman national
avec le sous-entendu de romans comme
comme invention
en fait je vais vous dire quand vous
entendez quelqu'un reproché le roman
national ne leur est pas ce qu ils vous
reprochent ce n'est pas le roman c'est
le national et ça il faut bien le
comprendre parce que c'est ça l'enjeu
donc non pas que j'invente un roman
national mais je je je raconte une
histoire du point de vue français c'est
à dire que non pas je ne raconte pas
napoléon du point de vue anglais mais du
point de vue français
je ne vais pas raconter la guerre de
14-18 du point de vue allemand
mais du point de vue français je ne vais
pas raconter la colonisation et la
décolonisation du point de vue des
colonisés mais du point de vue français
encore une fois ça ne signifie pas qu'on
a toujours raison ça signifie simplement
qu'il faut se réapproprier son histoire
pourquoi faut-il se réapproprier son
histoire c'est la seule solution pour se
réapproprier son pays et c'est la seule
solution pour qu'on se sente de nouveaux
français il ya vous savez une très jolie
formule de deux d'andré soir est un
grand écrivain malheureusement oublié
aujourd'hui et qui dit il ya deux types
de français il ya les français par
l'esprit et ya les français par la chair
et les français par la chaire bon ils
sont là depuis des siècles c'est simple
ils sont français ils sont jamais posé
de questions
et puis il ya les français par l'esprit
qui viennent d'ailleurs et eu auparavant
et j'en suis sans doute la dernière
génération ont les rangs des français
par l'histoire de france c'est à dire
que on s'approprie y est les héros de
l'histoire de france et moi j'ai grandi
quand j'avais quand j'étais enfant je
rêvais d'être dans les batailles de
napoléon je ne comprenais pas pourquoi
il était allé en russie et je rêvais de
lui dire mais mettez vous arrête toi là
voilà c'était ça avant et on regardait à
la télévision
vidocq on regardait les choux majster
l'espion de l'empereur c'était les
séries qui vous raconter encore plus
l'histoire de france ça c'était mon
enfance c'est comme ça qu'on devenait
français par l'histoire de france est
aujourd'hui justement la grande bataille
de l'histoire c'est que les historiens
estiment qu' il faut raconter à chacun
l'histoire de ses origines alors on va
raconter au petit arabe l'histoire du
maghreb on va raconter aux petits
africains
l'histoire des royaumes africains on va
raconter aux petits asiatiques
la grosse glorieuse histoire de la
cochinchine avant la france est après la
france et on va leur expliquer que les
français ont été de méchants
colonisateur entre parenthèses la
plupart ne serait pas né s'il n'est pas
eu la colonisation française puisque il
mourrait tous comme comme tous les pays
tellement pauvre qu' il n'y a vait c'est
la france qui a apporté la médecine et
qui a permis de d'arrêter le la
mortalité infantile massive qu'on
connaissait dans toutes les sociétés
traditionnelles donc mais à part ça on
va leur expliquer que la france a été un
méchant colonisateur et qu'ils doivent
récupérer leur culture ça c'est leur
meilleur moyen de désintégrer la france
et c'est exactement ce qui a été réussi
c'est à dire que chacun estime qu'il est
de son origine de son de sa culture de
de sa race comme dit houria bouteldja et
qu' il doit prolonger son histoire y
compris sur le sol français et que
l'histoire de france n'est que
l'histoire des gaulois mais que
l'histoire de ceux qui étaient là avant
et qui sont des puisqu'ils nous
ont colonisés
c'est ça exactement à quoi on est arrivé
alors que l'histoire enseignée
auparavant je raconte dans mon
introduction une phrase absolument
extraordinaire d' alfred grosser sais
pas si vous vous souvenez de ce nom
c'était un historien qui qui comptait
quand moi j'étais à sciences po et qui
était très importante
et son père était allemand et son père
avaient été médecin dans l'armée
allemande pendant la guerre 14
donc oui il était du camp allemand répit
dans les années 20 30 il arrive à paris
il devient français et dans les années
50 il fait un court et il raconte
l'histoire de la guerre 14 et à un
moment en parlant des soldats français
il dit nous et là il a un un moment de
réflexion tout en continuant son cours
il dit je me disais j'ai dit nous en
parlons des soldats français alors que
mon père était en face assimilation
parfaitement réussi napoléon et mon
grand-père et jeanne d'arc et mon aïeul
et goethe n'est qu'un un grand écrivain
étranger
ça c'était l'assimilation française de
l'ancien temps aujourd'hui le même vous
aurais dit mais non je suis allemand je
vous l'aï dit mais tu as une carte
d'identité française oui mais ça fait
rien je continue d'être allemand c'est
ça les deux enseignements de l'histoire
c'est ça l'enjeu historique et si vous
voulez cet enjeu historique est
essentiel est majeur et vous avez bien
compris parce que les guerres
d'historiens on en a toujours eu dans
l'histoire de france
on a eu les plus anciens se souviennent
la lecture communiste de la révolution
et la luxure libéral furet et compagnie
de la révolution avant on avait eu la
lecture monarchiste le grand bain ville
et puis la lecture républicaine les aux
larmes à thiès qui s'engueulaient en
plus entre eux parce qu'un avec été
tantôt nice et les autres qui étaient
robespierristes et puis avant alors là
c'est vraiment pour la petite histoire
et celle le plus amusant sous l'ancien
régime
on avait eu l'opposition entre les
mérovingiens et les romaniste là moi
j'adore cette opposition c'est à dire
que les mérovingiens disait que les
aristocrates c'était les francs et que
le tiers état c'étaient les gaulois et
que les apps les privilèges des
aristocrates venait du fait que ils
avaient été les vainqueurs
mille ans plus tôt et que donc le tir et
à n'avait qu'une chose à faire se taire
et la monarchie française très inquiète
de cette divise
de la nation française a fait monter au
créneau des historiens romaniste qui ont
expliqué mais pas du tout la france
c'est le descendant de rome c'est le
descendant de rendre de l'empiré romain
c'est d'ailleurs la thèse que je défends
mon livre je pense que la france et rome
au carré c'est à dire rome le
catholicisme et rome l'empiré romain et
c'est pour ça que je vous parlais tout à
l'heure de mon magnifique empire de 1810
mais pour vous dire l'influencé
politique des guerres de l'histoire vous
savez très bien pour les communistes et
les libéraux vous savez très bien que la
lecture communiste a influencé des
décennies de deux batailles politiques
et d'enjeux politiques mais pour revenir
à mes petits romaniste et mes petits
mérovingiens dès que la révolution
commence et que il ya un affrontement
évidemment entre le tiers état et les
aristocrates seyes dit mais si les
aristocrates ne sont pas contents qu'ils
retournent dans leur forêt de franconie
trois ans plus tard ils sont tous sous
la guillotine
vous comprenez ce que je peux vous dire
c'est que en france les guerres
d'historiens ça finit par des guerres
politiques et les guerres politiques ça
finit souvent par des guerres civiles
c'est la grande halle c'est une des
grande leçon que je tire de ce travail
c'est ces mêmes c'est même terrifiant
en vérité à quel point ça marche à
chaque fois quelques mois avant la
révolution de 1848 lamartine écrit une
histoire des girondins qui est un énorme
succès qui réveille la nostalgie de la
révolution et c'est la révolution de 48
et c'est là martin qui prend le pouvoir
on vit en france là dessus à chaque fois
qu'il ya des combats d'historiens qu'il
ya des affrontements d'historiens ça d
influence sur le combat politique
ensuite et très souvent car on est le
pays des guerres civiles on est le pays
des guerres de religion
ça finit on a un vrai affrontement les
armes à la main et c'est pour ça que cet
enjeu historique aujourd'hui que
j'essaye de vous expliquer avec des
historiens qui nous disent que il faut
que chacun continue l'histoire de ses
origines on voit bien où ça mène ça mène
tout simplement la désintégration
française et avec les pétés territoire
avec des populations qui vont dire mais
moi je sais je ne participe je ne veux
pas poursuivre l'histoire de france
moi je veux par pour voir poursuivre une
autre histoire j'ai rien à faire avec
ces gens là c'est ça qu'on est en train
de vivre
on est en train de vivre la partition
comme dirait françois hollande françois
hollande lui même l'a dit que ça
finirait par une partie il faut bien
comprendre que et ça je pense peut-être
que je me l'heure je pense que ça a
commencé dans la la conception qu'on
avait de l'histoire de france et je
pense qu'on nous a changé l'histoire de
france et ça en changeant l'histoire de
france on a changé l'avenir et c'est
pour ça que j'ai essayé de décrire ce
livre pour pour pour contrecarrer pour
contre carrer ça alors vous savez on est
toujours quand on écrit entre l'humilité
et l'orgueil démesuré humilité on sait
que ça ne servira pas à grand chose et
l'orgueil démesuré on croit que on va
changer la face du monde en écrivant un
livre on est toujours entre ces deux ces
deux approches et ces deux sentiments
contradictoires et j'espère que la
balance penchera un peu vers une
certaine utilité en tout cas merci de
m'avoir écouté
alors je vais vous demander d'accueillir
guillaume qui était qui et un celui qui
organise tous ces débats là où ils
applaudirent très chaleureusement
[Applaudissements]
l'auteur guillaume à son père dans la
salle qui est extrêmement fier de lui
moi j'ai ma mère dans un bassin qui
théoriquement est aussi un peu fier de
son fils et que eric à lui-même ses deux
enfants qui sont au premier plan et qui
le regarde avec admiration
maintenant je vais l'essayer guillaume
le soin de piloter les débats en
remerciant également tous les politiques
qui sont venus et qui j'espère vont bon
prix et vont prendre une grande leçon
d'histoire de france et notamment notre
secrétaire général annie genevard qui
étend des lointaines contrées franc
comtoise totalement racines et dans le
livre le destin national ne peut
qu'adhérer à ce grand combat de la
construction de la france guillaume un
grand merci à 1 à laurent pardon pour ce
retard laurent m'avait envoyé chez le
premier ministre et le premier ministre
parle des heures pour blablater pour pas
dire grand chose
d'où ce retard voilà en écoutant eric
zemmour je me disais qu'on avait
beaucoup de chance parce que eric vous
ne dites pas contrairement à ce que
disent des caricatures stupide vous ne
dites pas c'était mieux avant mais vous
dites on a une belle histoire une belle
histoire de france on doit être fier de
notre histoire et surtout nous qui
sommes engagés dans la vie publique
on doit être fiers d'eux l'idée de
poursuivre l'histoire de france c'est ça
l'action politique au fond pour suivre
l'histoire de france alors je suis sûr
que vous avez plein de questions syrie
quand on est d'accord on a peut-être
prendre deux ou trois questions par
série
dans chrome 2 3 on a les équipes de la
direction des études quant au micro
parmi vous voilà le voeu de lever les
mains allez-y là bas au milieu
ça marche
non si ça marche bonsoir monsieur merci
bonsoir d'être là cette fois je vois pas
mais c'est pas grave moi à ses vaches
marines j'ai besoin de vous demander
votre avis sur le mien et avant mais
avant je voudrais juste faire une toute
petite observation puisqu'on parle
d'histoire il est assez remarquable que
par a pratiquement aucun des médias ne
parlait de la mort du comte de paris
je crois qu'elle fait partie de notre
histoire pourtant bon ça c'est oui il ya
eu quelques papiers quand même bon bah
pas beaucoup france 3 france 2 bon c'est
mon avis c'était une parenthèse
il paraît qu'on est libre de dire ce
qu'on pense alors moi mon avis est que
la droite s'est construit un piège
l'année des présidentielles où cette
droite d'ailleurs qui était très désunis
à cette époque a eu très peur lors des
présidentielles de que marie jean marie
le pen passe à ces fameuses élections et
alors ce jour là
cette époque là les la droite s'est
allié aux socialistes pour hurler aussi
fort que et pour diaboliser le pen et
son parti mais ils l'ont diaboliser
exactement de la même façon que les
socialistes aussi fort et je pense que
c'est un piège qui est aujourd'hui se
referme sur laurent wauquiez et la
droite
ainsi deux personnes qui sont dit qu'à
partir du moment où laurent wauquiez
parler beaucoup comme marine le pen a en
tout cas son parti et bien il y en a
deux qui sont partis de ce côté à droite
puis il ya les autres qui ont trouvé qui
part qui parlait aussi trop comme marine
le pen sont partis plus à gauche
voilà alors ça c'est mon avis je
voudrais savoir ce que vous en pensez
alors je réponds tout de suite
euh comment on avoir attendront on va
prendre des deuxième question puis une
troisième on faire des séries 3 comme
vous êtes très bon goût amer madame
bonsoir oui tiens c'est à bâbord donc
voilà d'abord pour console et historiens
qui est pas de métier c'est pas grave
churchill a écrit une histoire des
peuples de langue anglaise qui et 8
seulement reconnu et on lui a reproché
de pas et historien de métier premier
point deuxième point dans le tous les
hommes politiques des grands chefs
d'état des gens qui ont laissé une trace
dans l'histoire ont tous été fana
d'histoire napoléon disait la vie d une
minute plus tard que si mes souvenirs
sont bons
bon argument supplémentaire le terme de
nation ou par la nation française dans
une chanson datant de l'époque de jeanne
d'arc
donc ce n'est pas une création nouvelle
c'est pas une invention de la république
voilà un dernier petit point alors je
suis entièrement d'accord avec vous je
peux pas poser de questions sur les
joues tu me donner des munitions en plus
mais j'ai un petit point de désaccord
sur le fait que la france est le pays
des guerres civiles
bon la guerre de trente ans et les
guerres de religion dans les pays
allemands qui n'étaient pas l'allemagne
les pays allemand je n'étais pas rien
non plus c'est vrai et avant les guerres
entre les villes et états italiens à la
fin du moyen âge c'était pas non plus
d'une franche gaieté vous avez les
l'italie n'existe pas la guerre civile à
dakar dans l'antre l'église italienne et
les états italiens avec c'était comme
une guerre civile parce que c'était
quand même les populations italienne
avec mu todo de langue d'histoire
voilà alors c'était juste des remarques
pas de questions les autres pour poser
des questions alors il troisième
remarque aux questions monsieur juste en
face de moi bonsoir vous m'entendez
oui je vous entends très bien revenons
en 1789 oui janvier-février cahier de
doléances mois de mai est un jeune héros
et le 14 juillet où me tuer
pensez vous que l'histoire se répète à
[Applaudissements]
ces mariages c'est marrant je
l'attendais cette question je dois être
et je dois être devin alors allons vite
moelleux la douzième personne n'y a pas
il n'ya pas y'a pas de questions ce que
je voulais dire sur le l'histoire des
guerres civiles vous avez raison il ya
des guerres civiles ailleurs c'est pas
du tout ce que j'ai voulu dire ce que
j'ai voulu dire c'est que la france y en
a tout le temps et que la l'histoire de
france est rythmée par les guerres
civiles et les guerres de religion c'est
ça que j'ai voulu dire mais on passe
madame pour le pen alors là c'est un de
nos grands désaccords avec laurent
wauquiez nous avons nous nous sommes
engueulés en public qu'en privé là
dessus donc je suis assez tranquille
pour vous dire que moi ce que je lui dis
je vais vous dire ce que je lui dis que
la gauche mitterrandienne a tendu un
piège à la droite
en séparant le rpr du front national
c'est une méthode qu'utilise la gauche
et là vraiment j'ai pu travailler dessus
et je soumets à la sagacité de laurent
cette histoire là parce que c'est la
méthode qu'utilise la gauche depuis le
début de la troisième république
ça a toujours marché entre les
légitimistes les orléanistes et les
bonapartistes et d'ailleurs c'est
exactement la même chose les orléanistes
c'est à dire les centristes sont
toujours ont toujours trahi et sont
allés à la gauche contre les
légitimistes et les bonapartistes c'est
une histoire qui se répète sans cesse de
pinceau
donc je pense effectivement vous savez
quand je vais voir quand il ya des gens
des électeurs du front national qui
viennent me voir j'ai l'impression de
voir les gens que les gens du rpr que je
voyais quand j'étais journaliste
politique à la fin des années 80 et
début des années 90 c'est exactement la
même sociologie
c'est la même typologie c'est en général
des braves gens qui étaient au rpr avant
et qui maintenant son front national et
charles pasqua
si je puis me permettre j'ai beaucoup
côtoyé charles pasqua avait dit à
jacques chirac en 1986 quand il avait
refusé l'alliance avec le front national
à l'époque il aurait mis trois ministres
font national et le front national était
mort deux ans plus tard exactement comme
mitterrand avait fait avec les
communistes
charles pasqua avait dit on leurre pour
l'instant c'est eux qui nous courent
après bientôt on leur courir après et
comme d'habitude charles pasqua avait
raison voilà ça c'est la deuxième que fo
ne m'a pas dit c'est pas trop parce que
vos kebabs engueuler après alors donc et
troisième question
ça y est mon alzheimer précoce avance la
troisième question les gilet jaune et
gilet jaune évidemment alors alors
question sérieuse oui il y a
dans les gilets jaunes la trace des
révoltes et des révolutions précédente
c'est une évidence il y à 7,7 ce côté
jacquerie même si les gilet jaune ne
sont pas des paysans mais en revanche il
ya ce côté jacquerie dans le fait qu'ils
ne sont pas dans les villes qui ne sont
pas habitants dans les villes et qui
sont extérieurs à la ville et donc c'est
une révolte de de gens extérieurs à la
grande ville où les richesses secret il
y a aussi le côté très révolutionnaire
français dans cette hargne anti monarque
alors évidemment macron a des
responsabilités personnelles mais il y a
chez les français ce rapport que
j'étudie d'ailleurs pour le roi frau
charles aussi c'est à dire que les
français ont été le peuple qui a le plus
aimés sombre aucun peuple n'a autant
aimé son roi même quand il était fou
comme charles otis smith
il compte continuer à l'aimer ça c'est
une spécificité française
donc évidemment vous allez comprendre de
l'amour à la haine
il n'ya souvent qu'un pas ce peuple qui
aime tellement ses monarques que quand
il le déçoive quand ils l'exaspère quand
il horripile il devient fou de haine
pour le même mot n'a qu on l'a vu ce
louis 15 était adoré au début de son
règne
on l'a enterré en catimini tellement il
était détesté il faut il faut voir ça
dans l'histoire de france je vous parle
pas de ce pauvre louis saez qui lui
justement a tout fait pour être
populaire et qui a fini sur la
guillotine
donc ça c'est vraiment une tradition de
l'histoire de france maintenant comme
toujours comme je vous ai dit au début
il ne faut pas se leurrer l'histoire ne
se répète pas de façon systémique c'est
ridicule c'est sans doute la première
révolte de la mondialisation c'est à
dire que c'est ce qui est
fondamentalement moderne c'est à dire
que les victimes de la mondialisation se
sont révoltés c'est à dire que il y a
vous savez j'ai coutume de dire
aujourd'hui il ya trois france il ya la
france des métropoles et la france
périphérique est cette france des
métropoles se subdivise elle même en
dessous partie la france des vainqueurs
de la mondialisation et sont tous les
deux les vainqueurs de la mondialisation
mais la france des centres villes
c'est à dire les gens qui comme nous ont
les moyens de vivre dans les grandes
villes à paris à bordeaux
voilà les grandes villes à londres etc
pour les autres pays c'est exactement la
même chose et puis il ya la banlieue
autour de centres villes qui sont aussi
des vainqueurs de la mondialisation
parce qu'ils sont d'abord à côté des
métropoles house où se créent la
richesse que ils viennent de l'étranger
où leurs parents leurs grands parents
étaient beaucoup plus pauvres qu'ils ne
seraient donc c'est une chance inouïe
d'être venu comme ça à côté des
métropoles et qu'en plus ils ont si vous
voulez un système qui qui est branché
sur les métropoles
il y a les gens qui travaillent tout
simplement il y en a beaucoup qui
viennent travailler ou dans les
métropoles qui ont les boulots que les
métropoles donne qui permette aux gens
des centres-villes de payer les
restaurants pas trop cher de faire toute
leur mode de va voir leur mode de vie de
façon
raisonnable il y à les assister et ils y
allaient trafic donc tous ces gens dans
les banlieues ils sont branchés sur les
métropoles
et puis vous avez le la france
périphérique et alors là c'est sale et
gilet jaune
c'est à dire des gens qui travaillent de
façon très modeste qui ont des revenus
modestes et qui sont les grandes
victimes de la mondialisation
c'est-à-dire eux ils ont subi la
désindustrialisation
ils ont donc ils ont pu comme ils
peuvent comme ils ont pu
ils ont mis leur fils dans les
municipalités
ça tombait bien la décentralisation a
permis une explosion des emplois publics
donc ça a fait un peu bouche trou mais
ça ne remplace pas l'industrie
évidemment donc la désindustrialisation
pourquoi la désindustrialisation
tout simplement parce que les emplois au
nom de la mondialisation ont été mis
ailleurs un en chine en turquie en inde
avait etc etc je vous tout le monde le
sait et puis ces gens de là de la france
périphérique
ils doivent travailler quand même dans
les métropoles puisque tout est dans les
métropoles dont qui font 50 km 80
kilomètres pour aller dans les
métropoles
d'où le évidemment le l'étincelle qui a
été la voiture et cette augmentation des
prix avec les taxes et tout ça voilà
pourquoi c'est cette révolte est en même
temps profondément moderne elle tire des
éléments du passé comme toujours mais
elle est profondément moderne c'est la
révolte des victimes de la
mondialisation contre les vainqueurs de
la mondialisation et d'ailleurs vous
avez remarqué que les uns et les autres
ne se sont pas mélangés
c'est très frappant c'est une c'est une
grande leçon de cette de cette révolte
et gilet jaune
il y a eu d'un côté la france dé gilet
jaune la france des petits blancs comme
diraient les américains la france de
johnny qui étaient là aux obsèques tu as
la madeleine voilà ça il y avait eu
et puis à vélo de l'autre côté les
métropoles je dis bien les france des
deux métropoles c'est à dire la france
des centres villes qui les a snobé
méprisés
insulter et
et qui maintenant les craint et puis il
ya la france des banlieues qui ne s'est
absolument pas mêler de cette histoire
moi mon avis est que ça tue tout
argument économique et social car vous
avez bien compris que selon les critères
économiques et sociaux il aurait dû
avoir des accointances avec la révolte
des gilet jaune puisque socialement tous
ces gens là sont très proches mais j'ai
toujours peur que tu es convaincu que ça
c'est la culture qui détermine c'est
l'identité qui détermine avant et donc
pour la plupart ces gens dans les
banlieues se foutent complètement du
sort de de la france périphérique c'est
ce que je vous disais tout à l'heure ils
n'ont pas la même histoire
donc ils se foutent complètement pour
eux ils n'ont pas le même avenir et au
milieu il ya la france des élites la
france dé des vrais vainqueurs de la
mondialisation qui joue avec tout ça et
qui essayent de survivre et de ne pas se
faire voler ni sa voiture ni sa belle
maison dans le 8e arrondissement
j'habite dans le 8e arrondissement merci
alors qu'ils lèvent la main
madame on vous entend pas ah oui parler
plus fort parce que déjà je suis myope
je vois rien donc si c'est la faute du
micro ou 100 ch à madame je me suis
beaucoup à la trace un vous
m'intéressait énormément je ne rate
aucune de vos émissions et de vos
interventions ces déclarations oui tout
à fait merci jamais intellectuelle je
voulais vous dire que je je ne crois pas
que comme on tente de vous présenter
vous soyez un passéiste
je crois que vous vous appuyez sur
l'histoire pour voir plus loin et je
voudrais vous proposer trois mots et
voir le lien que vous pouvez en faire
pour l'avenir
l'europe actuelle de bruxelles
la catastrophe démographique de l'europe
et l'immigration
alors ça tombe très bien passé bonjour
aux thomas tomasz zukowski lui ait l'air
de l'essonne c'est aussi je suis très
très loin derrière derrière les flashs
de vous me voyez pas forcé vue à
d'autres endroits mais je vais éviter
transition sur l'europe va merci 1
pouces vous avez fait sur le roman
français ou la réappropriation de notre
histoire et j'en profite que là c'est le
hasard des calendriers pour féliciter
l'ensemble des républicains et laurent
wauquiez d'avoir tenu bon sur la tête de
liste de monsieur bel ami
et il ya bien que les gens de lci pour
parler d'un candidat qui divisent je
sais pas trop qui divisent mais en tout
cas pas au sein des républicains au-delà
de ça voulue par le roman français et ça
fait partie d'un petit courrier que j'ai
envoyé alors ok je sais qu'il a lu c'est
la question de l'identité européenne est
en fait j'aurais une question pour
monsieur zemmour c'est qu'est ce qu'on
peut faire pour se réapproprier notre
histoire alors on peut quand on sera au
pouvoir réécrire les manuels d'histoire
avec un comité d'experts a lancé quelque
chose de scientifique mais de trouver
des appropriations qui comme des petits
garçons alors office appel charles
cantin tas de raisons qui voudrait dire
un peu celles qui ont présidé tout à
l'heure mais pour qui se projetaient
pour des héroïnes où les ou des héros
enfin je fais un pas de mauvais français
mais sur l'europe
quel serait votre votre conseil puisque
pour nous l'enjeu de cette élection
européenne c'est qu'est ce qui nous
réunit dans les peuples européens je
pense que quelque chose de trop oublié
c'est pour ça que je parlais de monsieur
bel ami parce que d'avoir un penseur un
philosophe et un philosophe est
forcément un historien des idées mais
pas seulement
il semble qu'il faut qu'on puisse
trouver notre héritage et notamment
chrétiens mais pas que romain latin
juifs l'héritage des lumières est donc
dans les propositions que l'airé
physique à nos vrais pour porter moi
j'avais fait une proposition verra se
ressentira d'avoir une université
européenne de la culture ou une capitale
européenne de la culture pourquoi pas
une capitale historique à trieste oms et
d'autres sujets qu'est ce qu'il faudrait
faire en europe pour se réapproprier
l'histoire européenne et auriez-vous des
auteurs à nous conseiller aux
équivalents sur l'histoire européenne
pour se réapproprier notre histoire
européenne commune puisque sur l'europe
on n'arrivera pas à avancer tant qu on
se connaîtra pas encore au point comme
on se connait pas entre français
troisième question monsieur à midi face
de moi
mademoiselle le micro s'il vous plaît
bonjour monsieur zemmour bonjour
monsieur zemmour soit moi j'ai une
question toute simple nous parler de la
désagrégation de l'histoire de france et
de la france
moi je voudrais savoir quel est le but
de ces personnes et si elles sont
identifiées et ici dans les 40 dernières
années il n'y a pas eu quand même des
alternances qui nous auraient permis
peut-être d'influencé ce sinistre destin
alors c'est assez simple et très
compliquée et chère madame en fait il y
a toute une école intellectuelle
française
j'expliquais sa dent dans mon précédent
livre surtout dont le suicide français
qui remonte à d'ailleurs des
intellectuels très brillant comme
foucault derrida gatard y est c'est qui
qui commande ayant pousse à la
déconstruction de la france et on
pourrait f
c'est ce que j'allais dire on pourrait
remonter très loin parce que c'est une
grande tradition des élites françaises
j'explique ça dans le destin si vous
voulez il faudra aller trop loin c'est à
dire que je pense que les élites
françaises ne supporte le peuple
français que quand il est en mesure de
lui donner les clés de la domination en
europe
quand il est en mesure de lui donner les
clés de la domination en europe ça
s'appelle louis xiv
ça s'appelle richelieu louis xiv
napoléon là les élites françaises sont
françaises et puis quand le peuple
français est vaincu alors là les élites
françaises estiment que ce n'est pas de
leur niveau et qu'elles doivent de toute
façon dominé l'europe et donc elles sont
prêts à se donner au vainqueur
alors elle se donne à l'anglais elle se
donne à l'allemand je vous passe les
détails elle se donne à l'américain elle
se donne
maintenant à bruxelles c'est à dire que
elle se donne à celui qui va leur
permettre de continuer à gouverner
l'europe puisque c'est comme ça qu'elle
se regarde dans leur miroir elle
considère les élites françaises se
considère comme plus intelligente que
les autres et donc doivent absolument
gouverner l'europe si le peuple français
n'est plus en mesure de leur donner ces
clés là eh ben ils vont chercher
ailleurs et là on a si vous voulez un un
détour de ça c'est à dire qu'on a des dt
des universitaires qui estime que la
france est morte puisqu'elle ne leur
permet plus de gouverner l'europe et
donc il faut l'achever il faut l'achever
et en plus elle habille sa toujours ça
c'est génie de la france c'est qu'on est
on est le pays de l'intellectualisme on
est le pays de l'abstraction né le pays
de concept tu n as écrit des pages
absolument sublime là dessus dans
laquelle il explique que tout part de
descartes est que nous sommes les le
pays de de l'abstraction et c'est pour
ça qu'on fait la révolution française
nous sommes le pays de l'abstraction et
donc nous sommes le pays de l'universel
c'est à dire que l'homme pour nous pour
nos intellectuels n'est jamais enraciné
dans une terre est tous assez vulgaire
il est il est un être pur et il est un
être universel d'ailleurs c'est là où le
laïcisme souvent anticlérical rejoint
nos racines catholiques catholicossat
vous dire universel mais c'est un
catholicisme dévoyé c'est les fameuses
idées chrétiennes devenues folles chair
hachée starten est donc cet
universalisme doigts et abolir la france
vous savez vous vous souvenez les
communistes voulait détruire la
bourgeoisie au nom du prolétariat et
bien ces gens là veulent détruire la
france au nom de l'humanité et encore il
estime que la france peut être fière
d'elle-même puisqu'elle va se sacrifier
au nom de l'humanité
ça c'est vraiment je pense le fond de la
faire là maintenant vous me dites la
droite là dedans mais ma pauvre ma
pauvre ami la droite là dedans
elles regardent passer les trains la
droite elle et elle est depuis 1789 elle
est terrorisé à l'idée d'être guillotiné
puis elle a été terrorisé à l'idée
d'être fusillés puis elle a été
terrorisé à l'idée d'être traités de
droite et elle a été terrorisée à l'idée
de ne pas être la gauche et de ne pas
être soumis à la gauche donc quand elle
n'est pas vous savez même le général de
gaulle même le général de gaulle a
laissé l'école aux communistes dire
c'est quand même c'est quand même quand
on y réfléchit deux minutes
incroyable mais même le général de
gaulle n'a pas compris cet enjeu là il a
laissé tomber il avait d'autres chats à
fouetter vous me direz et puis il avait
gagné de telles batailles sur la gauche
justement institutionnels et c'est que
là il n'a pas pu il n'a pas pu mener à
bien même napoléon qui rétablit en
vérité une monarchie sur le dos de la
république de la révolution eh ben il
fait accord avec les jacobins
la france est le pays de la révolution
française et donc ça a des conséquences
sur la politique française est sur la
droite il n'y a pas ça ailleurs
il n'y a pas ça en allemagne a passé en
italie il n'y a pas ça en angleterre
il n'y a pas ça en amérique vous savez
hannah arendt dit j'ai lu dans un arendt
quelque chose absolument que je trouvais
fulgurant elle dit pourquoi il ya eu la
révolution en france et pourquoi il n'y
a pas eu la révolution en angleterre et
elle dit tout simplement parce que ce
qui était en 748 qui se sont révoltés
contre le roi en angleterre ensuite on
les a envoyés en amérique et donc ils
ont fait l'amérique est donc la
population de futurs révolutionnaire eh
ben elle a fait l'amérique et nous on a
gardé nos révolutionnaires et on a fait
1789 et je pense que ça donne une
histoire complètement différente et
ça et que ça rend la droite et bt c'est
très compliqué pour la droite en france
de penser parce que immédiatement la
gauche lui dit non mais là c'est pas
bien du double à ce que tu fais les
objets du ballet donc et la droite se
couche alors les autres questions
démographie l'europe et la culture en
écriture au cellier d'ailleurs tout ça
oui il ya une civilisation européenne
oui il ya une culture europe il ya des
cultures européennes
oui il faut il faut les faire connaître
moi je évidemment tout ça est vrai qu
est ce que je peux vous conseillez moi
je j'ai fait ma culture entre guillemets
européenne tout simplement par la
lecture des romans quoi j'ai lu j'ai lu
kundera j'ai lu ce mec j'ai lu j'ai lu
kadaré j'ai lu dostoïevski j'ai lu
tolstoï j'ai lu voilà j'ai même lu des
auteurs allemands c'est dire
j'ai lu et
donc voilà c'est je pense que c'est
comme ça qu'on fait sa culture
européenne et qu'on voit à quel point
nos problématiques nos problématiques
sont communes à quel point notre
histoire est imbriqué à quel point
si vous voulez la france vous savez j'ai
l'habitude de dire mais ne le répétez
pas à l'étranger
pour moi la france n'est pas en europe
elle l'est l'europe c'est à dire que
vers dallas la france a pris des
morceaux de toute l'europe allait elle
est anglaise en bretagne elle est
italienne à nice
les allemandes en alsace les espagnols
dans le dans le sud-ouest et c'est la
france et l'europe et c'est pour ça
qu'elle avait un destin impérial mai
mais passée et maintenant évidemment
nous devons alors maintenant vous me
dites bruxelles le problème de bruxelles
c'est que bruxelles ils ignorent
complètement cette culture européenne
bruxelles et dans le dans une culture
juridique ou économique
qui ne connaît que le droit et le marché
et qui ne connaît que l'universel c'est
le vrai problème de bruxelles
à la limite on pourra connaître les
cultures européennes par des accords
avec les autres pays par une
connaissance des autres pays en allant
visiter les autres pays d autres nations
je vais pas vous refaire le numéro du
général de gaulle sur götze dante et
chateaubriand qui ont été grands parce
qu'ils étaient en allemand en français
en italien est pas en volapük mais il
avait raison là dessus
c'est tout le problème de la commission
de bruxelles qui elle n'est que dans une
logique juridique et économique
maintenant pour la démographie pour
répondre à la question
vous savez je j'explique dans le livre
je reprends une scène d'un film que j'ai
beaucoup aimé ya 20 ans est un film
québécois qui s'appelle le déclin de
l'empiré américain dans lequel le prof
d'histoire commence son premier cours
aux étudiants en dix ans il y a trois
lois en histoire la première c'est le
nombre
la deuxième le nombre la troisième le
nom je vous laisse imaginer la suite
merci alors on a une question de
monsieur est ensuite deux personnes sur
ma gauche monsieur marché pas s'il
marche allié alors comme un exe mollet
les prospectivistes sérieux savent qu'on
ne construit pas l'avenir sur des table
rase du passé
ils savent aussi qu'il y a des tournants
à prendre et que c'est tourner en appel
des capacités de gouvernance du
changement qui sont exceptionnelles
aujourd'hui j'aimerais vous entendre sur
l'art et la manière de prendre le
tournant de sociétés exceptionnel dans
lequel nous sommes engagés
alors on peut dire tournant on peut dire
déry correction de dérive on peut dire
nouvelle ère on peut dire plein de mots
c'est votre question voilà un banc
d'essai pas beaucoup de chance
un gros point d'interrogation pour la
question n'est pas très bien vous en
sorte comme il ya deux questions de la
ration alors c'est le vieux truc de
chirac passons à la deuxième question
bonjour geneviève de la peau me dit je
vous pose cette question sur un
auvergnat
il n'y a pas que le révoquer célèbre en
auvergne il ya aussi mais aussi brice
hortefeux aussi ya la fillette ya la
fayette lafayette qui a créé les droits
de l'homme européen
la paye est qui et qui a pris fait et
cause pour les juifs lafayette
oui allez je vous écoute je sais que je
peux vous en apporter les preuves si
vous voulez oui mon aïeul a pris
vraiment fait et cause pour tout ceci
donc je suis je lui ai dit contraire
donc la chose qui à là question que je
vous pose c'est s'il était là à l'heure
actuelle lui qui idolâtrent et la
liberté
comment agir et il merci voilà vous avez
négligé là ça devient dur monsieur fini
aucune autorité sur la personne qui
donne le micro princesse la droite
allant jusqu'à les textes du moment
qu'on restaure
tout d'abord je vais vous saluer pour
votre courage vous avez parlé de bien
sûr merci beaucoup vous avez parlé donc
de l'histoire de france est très
important mais a même quitté il est allé
dans une école française egypte et j'ai
appris l'histoire de france bonsoir
beaucoup et donc voilà je voulais dire
que les éminents c'est pas trop grave
aucun qui peuvent répondre aussi à cette
question quelles sont les mesures à
prendre
actuellement puisqu'il ya une partie de
la population que non seulement vous
islamiser la france mais elles ont
justement charia nous et la france est
donc
il ya en a perdu beaucoup de temps
jusqu'à maintenant et la droite doit
être très importante pour trouver les
mesures adéquates
pourquoi aussi ne pas faire de
l'instinct qui va leur propre à la
france donc on ne peut pas faire de la
valeur internationale universelle qui
peut peut-être nous faire avancer tous
merci j'ai compris vous voulez qu'on
refasse la grande armée de napoléon et
qu'on occupe toute l'europe et comme ça
on imposera la laïcité à toute l'europe
et l'egypte avec moi je suis assez pour
un mais bon alors je vais essayer de
répondre parce que là vos questions le
tournage est pas très bien compris quel
tournant j'imagine
il ya beaucoup de tournants ce moment
comprends je je je pense que alors je
sais pas si c'est le sens de votre
question mais c'est comme ça que je
l'entends je pense que nous vivons et
c'était c'est aussi le sens de la
discussion sur les gilet jaune
je pense que nous vivons effectivement
un double tournant
le premier tournant c'est la révolte des
peuples
c'est à dire ce qu on appelle ce que les
élites appel avec mépris le populisme
moi je je je prétends que c'est le cri
des peuples qui ne veulent pas mourir
et là on commence à les entendre
sacrément alors ils n'ont pas toujours
raison
ils le disent pas toujours bien mais ils
crient de plus en plus fort et si on les
écoute pas ça va ça va plus que crier ça
va taper de plus en plus fort il ya une
brique site il ya eu trump il ya eu
salvini en italie je vous passe hors ban
et la pologne et l'autriche
je pense que là comme d'habitude la
france a une histoire à part c'est à
dire que nous on revisite notre histoire
révolutionnaire et ça se fait dans le
bruit et la fureur tout le tout l'enjeu
pour pour notre classe politique pour
nos politiques etc
c'est de canaliser cette fureur
populaire mais je crois que c'est
exactement le même cri qui est poussé
ailleurs les peuples refusent ils ont
étaient hébétés pendant 30 ans et ils
refusent la destruction programmée par
la mondialisation
je crois que c'est le grand événement de
ces dernières années et que ça va
continuer et que ça va tendre de plus en
plus fort et vous avez compris quand je
parle de mondialisation
j'entends toujours la mondialisation par
le haut et la modélisation par le bas la
modélisation parle ou c'est la
mondialisation économique que je dirais
américano-chinoises parler vite et vous
avez très bien compris ce que je veux
dire
on est pris en étau entre l'amérique et
la chine et la mondialisation par le bas
c'est évidemment le nombre le nombre le
nombre et dans ce nombre
c'est évidemment l'islam qui comme l'a
très bien dit monsieur charia is une
grande partie du territoire français
et si vous voulez je pense que là nous
avons les deux tournants majeurs pour la
france il y a une phrase de rené girard
que j'ai redécouvert dans son dernier
livre qui s'appelait achever clausewitz
il est mort quelques temps après et dans
ce livre il disait il nous faut entrer
dans une pensée du temps où la bataille
de poitiers et les croisades sont plus
proches de nous que la révolution
française et l'industrialisation du
second empire
je pense que cette phrase est
prophétique et que c'est le deuxième
tournant qui nous guette c'est à dire
que nous sommes aussi dans un moment
comme le dit claude vite
nous revenons à des parties complètement
oubliée de notre histoire et les partis
qui nous ont occupés depuis deux siècles
la révolution française et
l'industrialisation du second empire
s'éloigne peu à peu
donc ça c'est vraiment ils essayent de
se globaliser les réponses aux trois
personnes maintenant pour la fayette
je vous avoue chère madame que
vous allez vous allez me détester mais à
côté de napoléon lafayette c'est un an
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
franchement ça a été aussi un type très
courageux ça je dis pas ce qu'il a fait
en amérique c c'est très audacieux et et
c'était formidable mais c'était pas un
grand politique voilà c'est ça que je
veux dire et il a été manipulé par les
autres par des types qui était beaucoup
plus méchant et beaucoup plus pervers
des fous chez d'état les renvoyer qu'ils
ont manipulé parce qu'il était c'était
un brave gars qui allait qui avait pas
peur et ça c'était formidable
mais en politique il est tombé faut dire
sur des règles sur des types qui était à
la fois très méchant très intelligent et
très pervers et aux 48 il aimait bien
qu'on leur amène quand même un coup le
rappeur en mille morceaux qu'ils aient
moins 1830 excusez moi ça lui a bien plu
quand même alors après ces
considérations sur la fayette trois
questions qui sont plutôt là et
peut-être les dernières questions aussi
on est d'accord puisque ensuite eric va
dédicacer son livre tout ce qu'il
souhaite
monsieur bonsoir alors pour servir les
premiers mots de laurent wauquiez qui
nous parlait de soumission une question
petit peu provoc ne pensez vous pas que
nos mails ne pensez vous pas que nommer
le premier parti conservateur de droite
français les républicains et le site
même de la soumission idéologique à nos
adversaires
la gauche au regard de l'histoire qui
nous apprend que la gauche il fondé la
république et la droite justement
défendre la monarchie avant la tripe
division de la droite pour la partie sur
les amis et légitimistes donc nous avons
évoqué tout à l'heure
vaud qui m'avait pas dit que c'était
aussi variés les républicains ben bravo
bravo ça me rappelle les quand j'étais
jeune journaliste politique et que que
pierre mazeaud insulté michel barnier ça
me plaisait bien ça va nous faisait
beaucoup
il s'en vante plus maintenant barnier et
ça c'était assez drôle de les deux
autres questions lundi soir allez-y
alesi et jacou riche et pharmaciens je
suis un ancien élu de paris eric zemmour
vous avez donné une définition
universelle de la culture ne pensez vous
pas que la culture quand même c'est la
langue qu'on parle à l'intérieur d'une
maison c'est là c'est la gastronomie
aussi et c'est plein de de coutume
d'habitude que chaque famille peut quand
même à donner à ses enfants donc au sein
de l'union européenne je m'excuse mais
on parle pas la même langue et je pense
que quand on dit l'union européenne on
parle surtout et on n'ose pas le dire
ces religieux c'est à dire l'union
européenne européen la majorité puis
sont pour la plupart des catholiques
il faut pas oublier aussi qu'il ya des
musulmans en france comment vous voyez
l'intégration et musulmans au sein de la
nation française
parce que c'est à settat c'est un vrai
problème je pense est un vrai sujet je
vous remercie vous avez gratter 15
questions la fois la bravo la dernière
question avant qu'eric consacre les
trois heures qui viennent vous répondre
alors bon soir thierry thierry kiev 1 je
vais vous parler d'un terne qui est
beaucoup employé aujourd'hui que vous
avez employé
vous même tout à l'heure nos cieux
zemmour comment peut-on parler au sujet
des gilets jaunes de la france
périphérique alors qu'un centre de la
france se trouve dans le berry que le
centre que le centre de l'europe
économique et de l'euro se trouve dans
un département qui m'est chère qui est
la nièvre et que et que la france
périphérique est quand même bien au
centre de tout ça il me semble si mes
cours d'histoire était bon que la
révolution de 1789 est parti d'une ville
proche de chez guillaume larrivé qui
s'appelle clamecy il va toujours à
gauche d'ailleurs c'est est ce que vous
pourriez par hasard avec votre votre
pouvoir médiatique qui essayait de
ramener la france
ben au centre et que la france
périphérique soit vraiment la france
voilà dans sa diversité là vous me
prêtez un pouvoir que je n'ai pas écouté
la cc je vais essayer de répondre le
plus le plus succinctement possible plus
le plus clairement possible pour l'union
européenne je crois que le problème de
l'union européenne c'est que c'est un un
état sans nation
fondamentalement c'est ça c'est à dire
qu'il ya un fantôme d'état qui qui qui
donne ses instructions et avec l'aide
d'ailleurs des états européens eux mêmes
et il mais il n'ya pas de nation
européenne vous avez raison il ya une
civilisation européenne et tous les
équilibres subtils c'est de trouver des
accords entre nations européennes sans
considérer que nous sommes
il y aura les états unis d'europe
c'était le grand le grand mythe des des
fédéralistes et je pense que ce grand
mythe d'où ils doivent y renoncer
le problème c'est qu'un à certains
qu'ils n'y ont toujours pas renoncé
maintenant évidemment le lien d'ailleurs
c'était le projet d'origine des pères
fondateurs
c'est le catholicisme vous avez tout à
fait raison c'est évidemment le ciment
européen et d'ailleurs chirac et jospin
sont très coupable d'avoir empêché qu'on
le conte d'inscrits ville et l'ailé les
racines chrétiennes de l'europe je pense
qu'ils sont très coupable maintenant ça
aussi c'est dans la révolte colons
qualifient de populiste on voit bien que
les peuples se réapproprier leur origine
leur identité leurs coutumes qui disait
les coutumes c'est à l'inter de la
famille évidemment évidemment et elles
doivent continuer à être transmises ça
pour moi il n'y a pas de sujet là dessus
maintenant j'aurais du mal à répondre
sur l'intégration des musulmans car il
nous faudrait une soirée entière
c'est un vaste sujet et je pense
d'ailleurs que c'est un sujet qui est en
voie d'être réglé
si j'ose dire c'est à dire que il y à
une partition là comme pour parler
encore comme hollande il y à des
musulmans qui veulent sincèrement
devenir français qui sont devenus
français petit à petit je dis ça parce
que évidemment quand on vient d'un de
contrées étrangères on devient français
on s'approprie petit à petit la france
et c'est le parcours de tous les gens
qui viennent de l'extérieur qu'ils
étaient italiens etc et donc ça il y en
a ça existe même si je dirais que le
l'assimilation comme on n'impose plus
une assimilation
elle est de moins en moins bonne de
moins en moins bonne c'est dramatique
d'ailleurs pour les musulmans eux mêmes
mais ça c'est un sujet sans fin et puis
il y a dans nos banlieues
de plus en plus de territoire qui on dit
toujours les territoires perdus de la
république ce n'est pas les territoires
perdus de la république c'est les
territoires perdus de la france c'est à
dire que des territoires qui petit à
petit s'est
exclu du territoire français c'est le
tout la différence entre des individus
et des masses vous savez une phrase de
benjamin constant que j'aime beaucoup et
qui résout notre question et qui dit
tout et morale dans les individus tout
et physiques dans les masses un individu
est libre car il n'a en face de lui que
des personnes de de sa force
dès qu'un individu entre dans une masse
il n'est plus libre et ben l'histoire de
des musulmans français
c'est benjamin constant qu'il avait eu
deux siècles avant tant qu'ils sont
individualisés et bien évidemment qu'ils
vont se couler dans le dans le dans le
dans le don le giron français comme on a
tous fait dès qu'il devienne une masse
c'est-à-dire beaucoup de nos banlieues
c'est fini ils sont des franchisés qui
sont is larvée islamisée et elin et les
territoires vont doucement dériver vers
le vert le l'éloignement de la france
c'est un problème qui va nous qui va
nous tomber dessus et qui nous a déjà
tombé dessus merci à eric zemmour avant
que notre président laurent wauquiez ne
conclue et que eric des dédicaces
je fais comme toujours les annonces
après la masse si j'ose dire c'est à
dire j'annonce les prochains rendez vous
des idées
ce soir c'était le huitième 8e soirée
je crois que c'est probablement la plus
réussie le neuvième ce sera 40 et merci
beaucoup
9e ce sera le mercredi 27 février ce
sera au tour du thème le président et le
parlement et on fera un petit truc à
deux voix il ya maxime tandonnet qui
viendra présenter sa biographie tardieu
chez perrin et puis je serai de parler
aussi un peu de mon bouquin le coup
d'état macron et un mois après le
mercredi 20 mars ce sera luc ferry et
bernard acoyer luc ferry qui soucie
d'agenda au mois de janvier donc on fera
ça le 20 mars autour du thème de
l'environnement et de la science
voilà merci à tous la parole à laurent
[Applaudissements]
je voudrais juste alors c'est peut-être
l'agrégé d'histoire qui essaiera de
capter quelques leçons d'histoire
proposé par eric mais vous expliquer
pourquoi est ce que ces soirées sont
importantes
toute la politique actuelle est fait
d'une espèce d'attrition progressive
c'est de l'ultra communication c'est de
l'ultra court terme c'est de l'ultra
buzz
et c'est d'ailleurs des politiques dont
la vision devient de plus en plus courte
à tel point même que maintenant le
politique on est réduit adressé des
courriers avec des questions sont même
plus expliquer aux français quelle est
sa propre vision moi je ne crois pas je
ne crois pas qu'on reconstruira ni le
pays ni la confiance dans le politique
sur ces bases je pense que c'est
exactement l'inversé qu'il faut faire il
faut reprendre de la hauteur
il faut reprendre de la distance il faut
redonner du temps long pourquoi est ce
que quelqu'un comme eric est précieux
pourquoi est ce que quelqu'un comme luc
ferry est précieux pourquoi est ce que
quelqu'un comme finkielkraut est
précieux et pourquoi est ce que
quelqu'un comme bellamy est précieux
parce que ce sont des gens qui nous
permettent de re prendre de la distance
de voir ce qui se passe est d'essayer de
le comprendre l'histoire nous aide à
comprendre
elles nous aident à discerner ce qu'il
faut faire dans cette période
au fond quelle est la leçon d'eric notre
pays plusieurs fois a été au bord de se
dissoudre notre pays plusieurs fois a
été au bord d'imploser et notre pays
plusieurs fois dans son histoire a connu
cette période où un certain nombre de
censeur s'arroger le droit expliquer aux
français ce qu'était leur destin est ce
qu il devait poursuivre avec d'ailleurs
souvent cette espèce de pulsions
mortifères que eric a parfaitement
détaillé où on explique à la france que
pour réussir elle doit se renier et
changer de nature
à chaque fois il y a eu deux chemins il
y a eu le chemin de ceux qui ont pensé
que la modernité se construisait sur les
décombres de nos fondations et de nos
valeurs
ça aboutit à talairan ça aboutit à louis
15 sa
outil à tous ceux qui ont souvent plongé
la france dans de longue période de
recul et décadence mais il ya aussi
l'autre chemin qui parfois est notre
échange avec eric c'est moi je veux
garder l'espoir
inquiet les phases de sursaut les phase
de réveil celles qui permettent le
réarmement c'est celle de richelieu
c'est celle de bonaparte dans ces phases
là elles se sont toujours construites
sur une idée qui est au fond assez
simple la france doit se réapproprier ce
qu'elle est et retrouver sa fierté et
son destin c'est cela
cette leçon cette leçon c'est celle de
la france et c'est celle de la droite
parce que je suis convaincu qu'il ya un
lien consubstantiel dans ces périodes
entre ce que la droite à porte et ce
qu'est le réveil du pays à chaque fois
que la droite a été soumise
elle a accompagné la france dans la
décadence à chaque fois que la droite a
été lucide et qu'elle a permis le réveil
elle a organisé ces phases de sursaut il
ya eu de longues phases de soumission
que la droite a connu et vous me
connaissez je pense que dans ces
périodes là précisément nous avons toute
l'eau propre des censeurs qui est
concentré sur nous comme elle a été
concentrée sur eric pour faire taire ce
sont des périodes où est testé notre
résistance et ce sont des périodes où il
faut au contraire aller puiser en nous
cette énergie qui est celle des
convictions
le choix qu'on a fait aux européennes
c'est le choix d' affirmer ce que nous
sommes et de dire clairement vous ne
nous dicter pas les choix qu'on a à
faire le choix que nous faisons
maintenant joc nous faisons maintenant
c'est tout simplement un choix qui
consiste à dire il est urgent que la
droite ouvre une nouvelle page et que
cette nouvelle page permettent de
tourner toutes celles qui ont amené à la
fois au recul du pays et au recul de
notre famille politique c'est à dire
celle où petit à petit on s'est
recroquevillé en renonçant à nos idées
le livre d'eric zemmour c'est un livre
qui invite au réarmement intellectuelle
c'est un livre qui invite au sursaut des
valeurs c'est un livre qui invite à
réinstaurer du temps long dans la
politique française
eh bien c'est ce qu'on va faire parce
que si l'on est condamné à mourir et en
france la mort n'est jamais un destin
merci à tous
merci à vous merci à vous